le Journal du Dimanche à publier hier
sont palmarès annuel des villes où il
fait bon vivre avec une 23e place tours
s'en sort plutôt bien même si la ville
perd 5 places par rapport à l'an dernier
alors que faut-il penser de ce
classement comment voyez-vous votre
ville leur reportage de Clémence dosc
les tours
se classe à la 23e place des villes
françaises où il fait bon vivre
34820 communes françaises ont été
passées au peigne fin sur la base de 198
critères eux-mêmes classés en 10
catégories telles que les transports la
sécurité le commerce et nouveautés cette
année la protection de l'environnement
mais alors qu'en pense véritablement ses
habitants je pense que c'est une ville
agréable qui a été plus propre mais bon
ça dépend des générations sans doute
c'est une ville qui est agréable quoi
bon allez elle était plus fleurie avant
c'était je trouvais que les parters de
la de la place Jean Jaurès et tout ça
c'est beaucoup plus agréable c'est une
ville où il y a beaucoup d'étudiants
les bords de Loire c'est vraiment c'est
extra c'est très joli puis voilà c'est
central donc on peut aller à Paris on
est tout près le sud c'est pas trop trop
loin Bordeaux tour Bordeaux
c'est vite fait donc on peut être à la
montagne à la mer assez rapidement
j'aime bien le
thé ville à la campagne parce que je
suis j'habite tout près des parcs il y a
une petite chose que j'aime moins c'est
les la circulation
parce que je trouve que les vélos et les
trottinettes ont pris le pas sur les
piétons en Indre-et-Loire 5 autres
communes figure dans le top 500 parmi
elles Saint-Pierre-des-Corps
Joué-lès-Tours Chambray-lès-Tours et
Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire côté village la
commune de Saint-Genis parvient à se
hisser à la 212ème place classée 18e en
2022 tout aura perdu 5 places elle reste
toutefois la ville la mieux classée de
la région